قال الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيرينا الحرب في اوكرانيا كان لها تاثير
مدمر على الاوكرانيين في ظل تفاقم
التوترات والانقسامات العالميه واضاف
غوتيرش في افتتاح مؤتمر الامم المتحده
الخامس المعني باقل الدول المعقد في
العاصمه القطريه له الان الاوان لانهاء ما
وصفها بالوعود الكاذبه وجعل الدول الاقل
نموا في صلب اهتمام الامم المتحده داعيا
الدول المتقدمه الى دعم الدول الاقل نموا
لمواجهه اثار التغيرات المناخيه
انه الوقت الملائم لانفي البلدان المتقدمه
بالتزامها بتزويد اقل البلدان نموا بما
يتراوح بين 0.15 و 0.20% من الدخل القومي
الاجمالي للمساعده الاملائيه الرسميه ولن
نقبل الاعذار برنامج عمل الدوحه هو دليل
عملي لمعالجه كل هذه القضايا
ويحتوي على اهداف ونتائج ملموسه وادعو
شركائنا في التنميه الى دعم تنفيذ هذه
النتائج وتحقيق اهداف برنامج عمل الدوحه
عصر الوعود الكاذبه يجب ان ينتهي الان
دعونا نعطي احتياجات اقل البلدان نموا
المكان الذي تستحقه في قلب مشاريعنا
واولوياتنا واستثماراتنا